Termin einer Pressekonferenz zur
Stammzellspende
und an meiner Seite darf ich begrüßen
die Verteidigungsministerin Claudia
dem Präsidenten des Roten Kreuzes Herrn
Gerald Schöpfer und die past
gouverneurards Vorsitzende des Lions
Club International Frau Eva-maria Franke
sehr geehrte Verteidigungsministerin ich
würde sie um ihre Worte ersuchen ja
vielen Dank sehr geehrter Herr Präsident
sehr geehrte Frau Vorsitzende Franke
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren eine
Soldatinnen Soldat kann Leben retten das
nicht nur wenn
sie Rea und Einsatz ihres eigenen Lebens
das Land verteidigt sondern auch dann
und damit möchte ich beginnen wenn Blut
gespendet wird unsere Ehre
sanitätschefin ist auch und unter uns
und sie weiß auch dass unsere Soldaten
Soldatinnen und die zivilgediensteten
die sehr regelmäßig tun und zwar schon
seit dem Jahr 1972 also mehr als 50
Jahren und allein in den vergangenen
fünf Jahren haben die Frauen und Männer
meines Ressorts im Rahmen der
regelmäßigen blutspendetage
65.000 Vollblutspenden abgegeben
und damit zahlreiche Menschenleben
retten können ja und jetzt wollen wir
noch einen Schritt weitergehen wenn man
daran denkt dass allein in Österreich
jeden Tag drei Menschen am Blutkrebs
erkranken dann glaube ich müssen wir
diesen weiteren Schritt auch gehen wir
wollen nicht nur die Grundwehrdiener
sondern alle die im Ressort Blutspenden
und zwischen 18 und 35 Jahre alt sind
einmal im ersten Schritt bitten sich
euch
Stammzellenspender zu registrieren und
wenn ich Sie heute hier sehe dann wissen
wir wie wichtig das ist das auch wir als
Ressort hier einen weiteren Schritt
setzen denn bei Bluterkrankungen wie
eben Leukämie können diese gespendeten
Stammzellen und haben das getan das
Leben retten und die Wahrscheinlichkeit
für einen erkrankten dass man dann einen
passenden Spender findet oder eine
Spenderin findet die liegt bei
Verhältnis von 1 zu 500.000 und daher
ist es unglaublich wichtig dass sich
viele Menschen finden die sich für eine
derartige Spende auch registrieren
lassen ja und da kommen wir als
österreichisches Bundesheer ins Spiel
weil wir haben mit unseren
Grundwehrdienern und dem jüngeren Kader
aber auch den Zivilbediensteten eine
sehr große Anzahl dieser jungen Menschen
die sich durchaus gut als Spenderin als
Spender eignen und sich freiwillig und
darauf liegt natürlich auch die Betonung
in der Stammzellen Datenbank
registrieren lassen können das ist ein
weiterer Vorteil weil das ist keine
einmalaktion weil wir ja regelmäßig neue
grundwehr die da jetzt auch vermehrt
viele Frauen bekommen und auch zu viel
Zivilbedienstete in unserer kommen ja
und wir haben es im Vorfeld ja
ausprobiert bei fünf
registrierungsaktionen
den Kasernen Mautern Einsteig und langen
Leben es waren 356 Männer und sechs
Frauen die dabei als Stammzellenspender
registriert bzw typisiert worden sind
und da das wollen wir jedenfalls
erweitern
das alles kostet Geld jede dieser
Typisierung der Stammzellen
Registrierung kostet Geld und das wird
nicht zuletzt durch eine Spendenaktion
des Lions Club Österreich finanziert ich
glaube wenn wir heute hier stehen herr
Präsident Frau Vorsitzende wenn wir drei
heute hier stehen dann finden sich drei
Organisationen zusammen mit dem
österreichischen Kreuz mit dem
österreichischen Lions Club und mit uns
dem österreichischen Bundesheer die sich
zusammengeschlossen haben um bösartige
Erkrankungen zu bekämpfen einfach
Menschen zu helfen und Leben zu retten
das alles wäre bei mir im Resort nicht
möglich wenn sich nicht unsere wäre
sanitätschefin Frau Brigadier dr
Sperandio so großartig einsetzt dafür in
dieser Sache es ist auch zu danken
oberstars dr Berger und Vize Leutnant
Burgstaller die diese auch probegänge
die wir im vorher gestartet haben im
Bundesheer so gut organisiert haben ja
ich glaube bei allen schwierigen
Situationen Krisen Katastrophen zeigt
sich eines all diese Herausforderungen
sind dann so bewältigen wenn wir es
gemeinsam tun wenn wir es gemeinsam tun
jeder seine Fähigkeiten und Kompetenzen
Möglichkeiten auch einsetzt um das Beste
zu erreichen im kranken Menschen zu
helfen und daher ist das heute auch
wieder eine Gelegenheit um mich bei dir
Herr Präsident ganz herzlich zu bedanken
für die Jahrzehnte lange großartige
Partnerschaft und Zusammenarbeit aber
auch bei ihnen Vorsitzende Frage für
diese Bereitschaft auch das Lions Clubs
bei diesem neuen Projekt zu helfen
vielen Dank
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident des Roten
Kreuzes ich würde sie um ihre
Ausführungen suchen
wir haben eine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren liebe Frau Minister
wir haben ein wichtiges Thema hat dir zu
erörtern und dass das schon erwähnt dass
pro Tag drei Menschen an Leukämie neuer
Kranken
beide scheint auf dem ersten Blick nicht
so viel zu sein aber im Jahr sind es
1000 Menschen die haben Leukämie
erkranken und die Diagnose Leukämie war
vor vielen Jahren eigentlich fast den
Todesurteilen und heute können wir
diesen Menschen helfen dank der
Fortschritte in der Medizin wir sehen
das Blutkrankheiten durch
stammzellspenden eine Rille Chance auf
Heilung haben das ist eine wunderbare
positive Nachricht und wir sehen das 90
Prozent der Patientinnen und Patienten
tatsächlich eine Spender finden die
Suche nach einem Spender da
durchschnittlich 24 Tage und das ist
eine echte Erfolgsgeschichte
das Österreichische Rote Kreuz hat 2018
damit begonnen neben dem Blutspenden
eben auch eine eigene Kartei mit
potenziellen Spendern für
stammzellenspenden aufzubauen wir haben
heute eben unser fünfjähriges Bestehen
wir haben mittlerweile an die 60.000
potenzielle SpenderInnen werden
nun in Österreich sind aktuell im
stammzellenspenderregister ein
118.658 Spender registriert
rote Hälfte also von diesen etwa 120.000
Spenden sind über das Österreichische
Rote Kreuz im 60.000 registriert worden
wir verfügen ein sehr einfaches Tool zur
Online-Registrierung die vor allem bei
der jungen Zielgruppe sehr beliebt ist
die Botschaft ist klar der Aufwand für
jeden Einzelnen ist gering bei der
Registrierung aber die lebensrettende
Wirkung die damit verbunden ist nicht
unermesslich und umso mehr Menschen sich
international registriert und typisieren
lassen unser größtes die Chance auf ein
Leben für die Betroffenen
jeder Mensch trägt eine bestimmte
Kombination von gewebsmerkmalen auf der
Zelloberfläche die Wahrscheinlichkeit
und dass du schon erwähnt dass Spender
und sozusagen jemand der eine Spende
empfängt zusammenpassen liegt eins zu
einer halben Millionen also das eins zu
500.000 das heißt es zählt jede
Registrierung es ist wichtig möglichst
viele Menschen registriert zu haben weil
das erhöht die Heilungschancen besonders
gefragt sind junge Männer weil ihre
Spende aus medizinischer Sicht für
Patienten und Patienten am besten
verwertbar ist die Jünger ein
Stammzellspender ist desto schneller
werden aus den Stammzellen des Spenders
gesunde reife Blutzellen
und an dieser Stelle möchte ich daher
die Bedeutung unserer Zusammenarbeit mit
dem Bundeswehr betonen sehr sehr
herzlich danken dass es diese
Kooperation etwa beim Blutspenden seit
langer langer Zeit gibt das ist für uns
auch eine Möglichkeit ist neue junge
Blutspende anzukommen das ist wichtig
wir haben das Problem dass die
Blutkonserven nicht ewig halten sondern
nur 42 Tage deshalb auch Tabellen weil
wir jetzt mitten im Sommer sind auch
wieder sozusagen mitzuhelfen dass die
Menschen bewusst wird wir brauchen neue
Blutkonserven weil sie eben nicht ewig
kaltbar sind und gerade im Sommer gibt
es hier die Problematik
ja also herzlichen Dank aber auch danke
in Richtung Lions Club Frau Franke das
ist großartig und ich glaube das ist
vielen Österreicherinnen und
Österreichern gar nicht so bewusst wenn
ich wichtige Seile und hat
Zivilgesellschaft ist serviceklub sind
Lions oder auch rotary oder wie man
diese ganzen Clubs heißen erbringen
gewaltige Leistungen um unsere
Gesellschaft etwas am Rande der
Gesellschaft
lebenswerter zu gestalten um soziale
Probleme mithelfen zu lösen es werden
lernhäuser finanziert diese
stammzellenaktion ist sozusagen
dafür herzlichen Dank dass wir es uns
nicht möglich gewesen wir machen das
ohne staatliche Mittel sondern mit
privaten Mitteln und aber alleins Club
ganz ganz vorne Frau Franke herzlichen
Dank und bitte diesen Dank auch
weiterzugeben
ja und wir werden heute noch eine sehr
emotionale genesungsgeschichte vom
kleinen Michael hören der im Alter von
nicht einmal ein Jahr erkrankt ist und
der heute ein fröhliches aufgewecktes
Kind ist und dann starker großer Bruder
für seine Schwester
das ist ein konkretes Beispiel dafür
dass es sich lohnt sich zu engagieren
dass man tatsächlich Menschen damit eine
wichtige Hilfe geben kann und
menschenlichkeit und Freiwilligkeit das
verbindet viele
Serviceclubs verbindet auch die Politik
so sie gut läuft und natürlich auch das
Rote Kreuz und unsere bitte noch einmal
an die Medien bitte das publik zu machen
sie können mitwirken mit ihrer
Druckerschwärze dass tatsächlich sich
mehr Menschen melden dass die Aufrufe
befolgt werden und dass wir noch größere
Erfolge haben damit Menschen tatsächlich
retten zu können danke für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
abschließend würde ich Frau Eva Maria
Franke um ihre Worte aussuchen
sehr geehrte Medienvertreter Werte Damen
und Herren
Lions Clubs International ist die
weltgrößte Serviceorganisation und gemäß
unserem Motto wie surf sind wir
beschränkt und bemüht dort zu helfen wo
unsere Hilfe bringen benötigt wird aber
unsere oberste Prämisse ist es Menschen
zu helfen die unschuldig in Not geraten
sind
als ich im Jahr 2013 also vor zehn
Jahren erstmals mit den Thema
Stammzellspende konfrontiert wurde war
es für mich ganz klar hier muss etwas
passieren hier müssen wir Lions helfen
seit 2013 versuchen wir Lions nun die
Bevölkerung die Leute auf diesen Gebiet
schlecht bis gar nicht informiert ist
aufzuklären wie einfach hier geholfen
werden kann ich habe unzählige Male
gehört
da wollte ich eigentlich schon immer
dabei sein aber wo soll ich mich
hinwenden ich habe keine Möglichkeit
oder ich habe gehört wenn die
Knochenmarkspende bin ich nicht zu haben
aber wenn man die Leute dann aufklärt
dass wir von einer Stammzellspende
sprechen und wie diese abläuft und wie
eine Blutspende die vielleicht nur mal
länger dauert dann sind die meisten
dafür auch zu gewinnen
im Jahr 2017 wurde dann aus dem
nationalen Hilfsprogramm die intern als
internationale Programm kinderkrebs
bekanntlich ist Leukämie die häufigste
Krebserkrankung bei Kindern
in diesen zehn Jahren haben wir
unzählige
stammzellregistrierungsaktionen
abgehalten oft auch im Zuge von
Veranstaltungen bei Flohmärkten in
Einkaufszentren etc und im Zuge sollen
stammzell Typisierungsaktion kann ich
auf die Idee des österreichische
Bundesheer ins Boot zu holen den gerade
junge Menschen eignen sich natürlich
besonders gut als Spender wir dürfen ja
auch nicht vergessen das bereits
registrierte Spender mit der Reichen des
55 lebensjahres automatisch aus der
Datenbank Ausscheiden das heißt wir
haben eine natürlichen Abgang und den
heißt es wieder aufzufüllen und es
sollten ja immer mehr werden denn nach
oben zu ist es ja keine Grenze
wir dürfen auch nicht vergessen in der
weltweiten Datenbank sind zur Zeit über
40 Millionen registrierte Spender aber
wie wir schon gehört haben ist die
Chance einen passenden Spender zu finden
immer noch bei 1 zu 500.000 und da muss
wirklich etwas passieren
daran muss ich wirklich was ändern die
jungen Grundwehrdiener haben nun die
Möglichkeit auch das jüngere
Kaderpersonal neben der freiwilligen
Spende sich auch erst Stammzellspender
typisieren zu lassen bzw registrieren zu
lassen und können damit auch ein Zeichen
der Nächstenliebe ein Zeichen der
Menschlichkeit setzen
ich freue mich dass meine Idee in die
Tat umgesetzt und realisiert wurde
dieser gemeinsame Weg steht sicher eine
Meilenstein und der Bekämpfung von
Blutkrebs da
wir leihen uns haben in den seit 2013
nicht nur Aktionen abgehalten sondern es
haben die Clubs auch viel Geld gespendet
und diese erst Typisierungen zu
finanzieren es handelt sich dabei um die
wirklich stolze Summe von rund 300
350.000 Euro und selbstverständlich
werden wir leih uns auch in Zukunft
stammzelltypisierungen finanziell
unterstützen
abschließend möchte ich mich beeilen die
am zustande kommen dieses gemeinsamen
Weges mitgewirkt haben ganz ganz
herzlich bedanken und bitte vergessen
wir nicht jede neue Typisierung ist eine
Chance mehr eine Menschen das Leben zu
retten danke
danke sehr für diese Ausführungen unter
Stichwort Leben retten bringt mich zu
unserer abschließenden Geschichte und
ich darf eine Familie recht herzlich bei
uns hier begrüßen und zwar Sandra Stefan
und den kleinen bzw inzwischen schon
großen vierjährigen Michael und ich wage
mich hier nach vorne ich würde dich
ersuchen Stefan dich an meiner Seite
hier aufzustellen und vielleicht auch
kurz den Zuschauern im Raum aber
natürlich auch
unseren Damen und Herren hier zu
erklären wie eure Geschichte denn wahr
und was mit dem kleinen Michael passiert
ist ein herzliches Grüß Gott auch von
unserer Seite also unsere Geschichte
ganz kurz zu beleuchten der kleine
Michael der ist mittlerweile vier Jahre
alt er wurde 2019 Anfang 2019 geboren im
Jänner und alles ganz normal wie es
junge normale Familie erstes Kind steht
im Mittelpunkt sechs Monate alles wie
bei den anderen
kinderprobleme hat aber sonst alles
wunderbar
ja und im Juli dann die ernüchternde
Diagnose also auf seiner Hand wurde eine
leichte Schwellung festgestellt und wir
sind dann in Spital gefahren anfänglich
ist man von einer knochenwucherung
ausgegangen
kein Drama und so weiter zwei Wochen
später waren wir wieder im Spital weil
wir uns eingebildet haben dass auch am
Fuß schon Erleichterung aufgetreten ist
ja trotzdem er und am Tag danach hat es
dann der Oberarzt angerufen er würde
gerne einmal Blut abnehmen und ja dann
hat ein kleiner Albtraum auf unserer
Seite begonnen aufgrund der Blutanalyse
hat man dann natürlich sofort
festgestellt es ist Leukämie für uns ist
natürlich eine Welt zusammengebrochen
wir sind dann direkt von der Diagnose
eigentlich gleich mit dem Rettungsauto
ins St Anna bestellt worden und dann hat
er eine Prozedur begonnen die
ja nicht sehr angenehm ist für alte
Beteiligten wieder für Patienten nur für
die Angehörigen und
es ist noch einen Drehbuch abgelaufen es
ist uns alles genau erklärt worden wie
es vonstatten gehen wird wir haben wir
haben vier bis fünf chemotherapieblöcke
machen müssen
ja erste chemotherapieblock war bei uns
gleich einmal der intensivste also da
ist natürlich der Körper geschwächt vom
Krebs und da wird wirklich gleich einmal
mit mit
sehr intensiven Chemotherapie begonnen
ist uns wirklich auch dementsprechend
vor allem schlecht gegangen aber ja noch
kurzen Aufenthalten auf der
Intensivstation auch immer wieder Gott
sei Dank schlussendlich nach dem ersten
Block schon herausgestellt hat die
Therapie schlägt an
und das ganze
dezimiert gehabt das heißt wir haben
doch noch drei weitere Chemotherapie
Blöcke machen müssen weil sich bei
Michael dann herausgestellt hat noch das
war dann der nächste Tiefschlag dass er
zu den Hochrisikopatienten gezielt die
mit einer hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit
rückfällig geworden wären wenn sie denn
nicht Stammzellen bekommen also unser
positives unser positiver Punkt damals
war die Krebszellen sind weg im
Hinterkopf wo immer sie werden mit einer
hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit wiederkommen
und da war es dann so dass es geheißen
oder muss nach den Chemotherapien sofern
wie das alles überstehen auch
Stammzellen transplantiert werden und
dann wieder das Bangen begonnen wem wie
gesagt also Wahrscheinlichkeit 1 zu
500.000 ist ist eine Statistik die nicht
so schön ist das Betroffener aber das
wissen dass es eben sehr viele Personen
ägyptischen registriert sein und diese
Datenbank in Österreich und weltweit
doch sehr sehr viele
potenzielle SpenderInnen beinhaltet
schon Hoffnung gegeben und haben
irgendwann zwischen ich weiß es gar
nicht zwischen Block zwei und drei ist
dann die Nachricht
das ist vier potenzielle Spender gibt
für uns wirklich wenn
man es eigentlich nicht vorstellen also
für normale Leute also
verstehen können wie Leute vor Freude
ihm dann weinen aber in dem Moment ist
es halt wirklich
faszinierend von einem mitgeteilt wird
das ist vier Spender gibt und es wird
dann gesucht wer dann wirklich am besten
passt von den vier Spendern und hat
herausgestellt ein 19-jähriger junger
Deutscher
ist er Spende Frage gekommen und bis
dann im wie er dann zehn Monate alte war
ungefähr
transplantiert worden noch mal eine
nicht sehr angenehme Sache muss man
sagen aber es wird wunderbar
funktioniert und die zählen sind
angenommen worden
ja alles in allem ein ein Albtraum das
ganze muss man schon offen und ehrlich
sagen aber in der heutigen Zeit wie
gesagt ist der ist es alles schon die
Statistik und die Wahrscheinlichkeit
schon sehr hoch dass das alles
funktioniert und bis man schon gehört
haben es ist absolut kein Todesurteil
mehr das ganze sondern es ist immer
wieder gesagt man Kopf hoch die
heilungschancenter mittlerweile sehr
hoch und vor dem Sommer ausgegangen und
es ist eingetreten und der Michael ist
auch jetzt ein ein vierjähriger der
definitiv wirklich wie jedes andere
vierjährige Kind auch keine Spätfolgen
mehr hat keine Nachwirkung keine
Medikamente
Transplantation Wahrheit wirklich unser
ein bisschen miterlebt natürlich dass
der Michael jetzt doch recht Fidel ist
und unsicht darauf freuen da jetzt so
quirlig wird da ist jetzt gibt es
natürlich auch die Möglichkeit das
Spender und Empfänger sich fünf Jahre
nach der Transplantation dann auch
tatsächlich treffen was würden Sie der
Michael ist doch nur ein bisschen jung
aber was würden Sie stellvertreten
vielleicht für die Michael gerne dem dem
Spender sagen wollen oder was würden sie
ihn gerne fragen
ja also es wird sich ein ganz ein
emotionales Thema für uns werden wir
wollen sie natürlich mit ihm treffen
sofern er das denn auch will
für uns ist es immer wieder nicht
selbstverständlich weil wir auch selbst
noch ganz so lange jung waren dass man
mit 19 Jahren definitiv sagt
registrieren oder eigentlich schon vor
19 Jahren mit 19 Jahren gegangen das ist
selbstverständlich ist irgendwie fern
dass er dahin geht und sie registrieren
lässt und dann auch noch spendet und
dann auch nicht nur Stammzellen sondern
auch noch das Knochenmark also wirklich
top Sache für uns und also vollsten
Respekt
gemacht hat
sagen wollen man das ist liegt auf der
Hand es ist ich glaube das Drücken Worte
dann eh nicht aus man muss es dann jedes
Treffen auf sich zukommen lassen und es
ist während er sicher am Anfang einmal
drinnen fließen und die werden sie
einfach austauschen im Sinne von die
ganzen es ist ja doch der Spender ist
doch jetzt ein Teil von Michael und
nicht unwesentlicher also das ganze
Blutsystem beruht auf dem das Spenders
natürlich und ja Michael ist man sich
jetzt nicht ganz so aber er ist sehr
sehr hyperaktiv natürlich Energie ohne
Ende und wieder das wirklich sehr
spannend sein wieder Spender ist ob man
da jetzt irgendwas ein interpretiert im
Sinne von und der auch so ist dann kann
man sagen ja okay also ja
danke für diese Einblicke danke auch
Stefan ich würde jetzt
[Applaus]
ja bevor wir die Pressekonferenz für
beendet erklären noch mal der Aufruf und
wir werden uns jetzt auch gleich live
anschauen wie so eine Registrierung denn
funktioniert denn es ist wirklich sehr
einfach sich zu registrieren Leben zu
retten und zwar nicht nur mit
Stammzellen sondern auch wie wir es
gehört haben mit Blutspenden und in
diesem Sinne sage ich Danke erkläre die
Pressekonferenz für beendet und ich
würde sagen wir schauen uns die
Registrierung praktisch an danke